hey what's up guys my name is a Cherno
and welcome to another vlog so today
we're on some mountain I don't even know
if you could call it a mountain is
probably more of a hill but it is pretty
frosty out here as you can see like five
degrees out I don't know how long I'm
going to stay here I do have my doctor
my duck down jacket so should be okay so
today we're going to talk about
University or College is the university
necessary should I go to university it's
a pretty serious question I want to try
and do my best to answer this with
regards to my experience and my opinions
on this but just be aware that these are
my opinions I'm not I don't want to tell
you what to do with your life but this
is just my suggestion and how my life is
has kind of played out let's do a cool
transition
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
color
all right University but first one to
listen to some free audiobook and
support the channel while you're at it
check out audible there'll be a link in
the description for a free 30-day trial
in which you can listen to some free
audiobooks I've been listening to some
pretty cool programming ones that I've
lost the links alert to definitely check
those out and also whilst we're also
talking about stuff that isn't actually
part of this video few of you guys have
been asking me what kind of gear I use
and what backpack I use I've got that
stuff linked in the description below
one of the reasons I love this backpack
so much is I can sit on it I'm literally
sitting on the backpack right now
instead of sitting like on the snow on
the ice this is this is a lot better I
just love coming out here and just
sitting down and just reflecting on life
you know like I'm sitting here right now
on some mountain which I'd never heard
of before I stumbled upon it and thought
huh this is the cool place I might check
this out I've ever heard I've never been
to this place before never even heard of
it but here I am five degrees my shoes
are wet because I didn't wear boots
because I didn't expect there to be ice
on the ground anyway let's talk about
University so is University important
should I go to university I'm going to
be answering this from kind of a
software engineering point of view
different industries maybe slightly
different but I think the premise is
going to be mostly the same it also
highly depends on what university you
end up going to so this is a little bit
of my experience with University in
general and my opinions and
recommendations as to what you should do
with your life but again it is your life
please do what makes you happy please do
what fulfills you this is just my
experience in my suggestions for those
of you that are interested so is
University important my opinion yeah I
think University is important but you
should not expect University to teach
you everything in fact you probably
shouldn't expect University to teach you
anything I can kind of hear footsteps
behind me but I can't see anyone
I thought that I would go to university
and suddenly all of my kind of computer
science all of my programming questions
would just get answered immediately and
it would be exactly what I wanted and it
would I honestly was so excited to go to
university I couldn't wait for I
remember the three-month break between
high school and university just
between finishing high school and that
that kind of that summer break when I
was kind of at the end of it was three
months at the end of it I remember I was
like oh man I'm just two months in or
something I was like like I I just want
to go Union right now like I'm done I
want to get into programming I want to
start this but when I got there things
were a bit different than I expected and
I thought that it might change as kind
of time went on but it just didn't and
so University man
well I even began so computer science is
generally an interesting field because
it's an incredibly dense field it's
something that's there's so much in
computer science that no no degree is
ever going to teach you it no no course
that you take in uni is just going to
teach you computer science because
that's such a massive field that's like
saying you okay you're going to learn
astrology or something I astronomy right
like we don't even know everything there
is to know about that how can we
possibly teach something like computer
science in a complete package in like a
few years that's going to be completely
impossible so every University is going
to offer a slightly different computer
science degree and the one that you kind
of choose is probably going to depend on
what you're interested in getting out of
the degree what kind of what kind of job
you're really looking for self learning
right universities are all about self
learning what that means is that you
will get assignments you will have exams
but really it's up to you to actually go
the extra mile and teach yourself what
you want to know the actual content in
my experience in university that I
learned in terms of programming was very
very kind of entry level right I mean
they taught you they taught you a
language my university had some horrific
structure to some of their units and
subjects I'm not even going to talk
about that because it's just going to
make me upset but in general university
is kind of structured in such a way that
they teach you the basics and then give
you the opportunity to go the extra mile
if you want to what I mean by that is
that you might have a subject where you
have weekly assignments that are very
simple and to do with what you're
actually learning there might be
teaching in a language for example but
then at the end of the 12 weeks of the
semester there might be a project that
you can do a lot of the subjects or
units my university call them units so
if I say unit in the future it just
means subject basically
a lot of the way that my units were
structured were they would have those
kind of assignments kind of in the
beginning of the semester but then
ultimately if you want to get a
distinction or a high distinction you
have to take on some kind of project and
a high distinction you have to also do a
research project so you can scrape by
with a pass or a credit we're doing very
very minimal amount of work if you can
answer some simple questions and write
some basic code you're probably going to
be done there's nothing really hard
about it you just need to be able to
follow up instructions and memorize a
few things but if you want those higher
grades you need to put in the effort and
actually spend some of your own time
coming up with something and then doing
it it's basically basically basically
you're paying University so that you can
teach yourself and it was very very
weird and I don't really agree with that
model and it's not all courses are
probably like this but again this is
about my experience so because of that
it was very focused on self learning
right we had lecturers of course who
were actually smart and who knew what
they were talking about well most of
them anyway but then the tutors that we
had during the lab sessions or the
tutorials throughout the week were
pretty much the second year or third
year students they were actual students
I remember during my first semester I
asked my tutor
hey like could you please answer this
question for me and she was like oh I
don't know I don't know the answer to
that that's outside of the scope of this
unit and I'm like I know it's outside of
the scope of the unit but I'm just
interested and she was like I don't know
you're going to have to ask the lecturer
stuff like that man like again not all
universities have this tutors of
students thing but my one did and it was
kind of cool but on the other set on the
other hand like they had no idea so I
went to lecturers because I was doing
those projects that we had to do and I
had questions I wanted to make my
project as cool as possible I had I ran
into problems I had questions that I
wanted answered and here's the problem
with a lot of lecturers their career
academics what I mean by that is that
their whole life has just been about
being in university and teaching right
they went straight from university to
university to teach and the problem with
that is they have no real-world
experience they don't know how stuff's
actually done they've read about it sure
but they don't actually know like they
don't actually know how the world works
they don't have real-world experience
they haven't gotten their hands
they don't they don't know how the
industry works they don't know what
people actually do in the industry so
they're kind of by the letter kind of
career academics and that's bad for a
few reasons first of all they don't know
a lot of the answers to questions and
and another reason that it's not so
great is that they think that every
solution to a problem has to be perfect
that's not how the real world works
there are so many hacks in software that
you and I use every day that no lecture
no career academic would be like yeah
that's acceptable but everyone in the
industry would be like well look it
works and it's fast so shipping so that
was my experience not very helpful there
were there were a handful of lecturers
at my University who actually did come
from the industry and there were
basically just 50 year old people who
had retired from the industry and had
gone into teaching which I think it's a
great idea because first of all well I
mean I even I enjoy teaching I probably
see myself doing that one day but also
they know what they're talking about
because they've had years of experience
in the industry not something the career
academics have they were much more
valuable and I definitely made friends
with lecturers who had experience in the
industry and the thing is the funny
thing is I didn't even know a lot of the
time it's not like I was like okay I
want to be friends with you but I need
to know like what your industry
experience is that wasn't anything like
that it was more or less I liked them
because they could answer my questions
and because I liked their answers I
could kind of communicate with them a
lot clearer because they knew what they
were talking about and then we kind of
became friends
so anyway self learning that's what
university is about and you will get out
of university what you put into
university so as I mentioned we have
these projects that we have to do we
like for example I did a unit called
games programming and to get a
distinction or higher you have to make a
game now of course I didn't have to do
that I could have just settled with
completing the assignments and then
that's it I would have got a credit or a
pass and technically I would have passed
the unit but no you don't stop there if
you want to be successful absolutely you
don't stop there you go for a high
distinction because first of all it's
not even that hard to get a high
distinction second of all it really just
relies on your doing work and what I
mean by you get you get out of it what
you put into
is that game that we had to make a lot
of students made something like space
invaders or pong right I made minecraft
i made a little minecraft clone now did
i know how to make minecraft at the time
absolutely not I'm not saying that I was
smarter than those people who made pong
or made space invaders absolutely not
it's just that it's just that I was
willing to actually put in the work and
dive into the deep end and learn
something completely new that I had I
barely had like I barely had 3d graphics
knowledge at that point like I I just
made a Minecraft clone in C++ using
OpenGL had no idea how to do it but just
I just made it work right I put in the
hours and I made it work and the reward
is that I now know I know I learned so
much from that I now know how to do that
can you credit the University for that I
mean not really they didn't teach me how
to do it but what they did do was give
me the opportunity to spend some time
they gave me the excuse to send more
time on programming because I was doing
it for a university assignment if I
didn't go to university or if I just if
I did some completely separate degree or
something and I didn't have that that
kind of self-guided projects and I it
would be hard for me to justify spending
that much time because none of us so
much other stuff to do but this is for
university I have to do this work right
it's basically homework I'm working on
an assignment whereas I'm really just
making minecraft right you get what you
put in so yes I would say you should go
to a university it will at the very
least give you the excuse to be spending
so much time teaching yourself and I
know that sounds weird why would I pay
to teach myself is it's weird I know but
it's just how it works
that being said if you're trying to pick
a university and you're not sure which
one to go with I would say pick a
university that gives you work
experience the reason I picked the
university I went to even though it was
not the most prestigious university in
fact it was actually fairly terrible
there were a lot better universities out
there however I wanted to go to this one
specifically because for every course
that this university offered they
offered work experience so no matter
what course you did you were basically
as long as you had above a credit
average but it's like 60% so if you can
get above 60% in terms of like 60% on
all your assignments which I mean should
be Pelle
felly achievable you
be eligible for either a six-month or
12-month placement in the industry and
this was fully paid like you had a
salary you had a fairly reasonable
salary actually and there were a whole
bunch of companies that you could apply
to and it was just like getting a real
job they taught you how to write a
resume and a cover letter you applied
for the job and then you would get it
that's how I actually started working at
ei through this work experience program
I was able to apply and they got me in
for an interview and then they hired me
I'll definitely make a video in the
future about that whole process how I
actually got a job at EA but that work
experience program was by far the most
valuable thing because it gave me the
chance to work 12 months in the industry
which first of all is going to be more
valuable than any degree you get anyway
if I'm an employer and I'm looking
through resumes and I see someone who's
fresh out a unit with no experience
versus someone who's fresh out of uni
but has a year of experience in the
industry that person is likely going to
be 10,000 times better than the other
person because of real-world experiences
what counts University as I just
mentioned doesn't really teach you that
much but working in the industry teaches
you so much and you'll actually notice
that in a lot of job descriptions when
you're looking at the requirements
they'll usually say something like
Bachelor of Science or equivalent
industry experience because that
industry experience if you've got that
who cares about your bachelor degree
what that doesn't matter you've had
experience in the industry in the
professional industry so much more
valuable so to sum it up yeah I do think
you should go to uni however don't think
that they're going to do the work for
you don't think that you can just follow
the course and you'll be fine you need
to be doing stuff yourself you still
need to be taking on personal projects
and university will likely give you the
excuse to spend a lot more time on your
projects and do something extravagant
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video I'm going to get out of here
because I am absolutely freezing you can
follow me on Instagram as always I'll be
posting a lot of the stuff that I see
around me on Instagram dot-com 4 - the
channel so definitely follow me back if
you guys have any more suggestions for
questions that you would like to see me
answer just leave a comment below and I
will try to get them of you guys next
time goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]